have you ever been watching a movie or a
TV show and you saw an actor doing a
thing that you know a lot about and they
are just not doing it right well we have
and that thing we know a lot about is
microscopy and there are plenty of
examples out there of movies and TV
shows that get microscopy right and then
there are others that show a scientist
looking through a microscope that has no
objectives attached to it and yes that's
a real example of something we've seen
in a TV show but instead of just sitting
there wanting to shot at the screen we
have decided that exclusively for our
patreon patrons we're going to record a
microcosmos reacts video where some
members of our team will be reacting to
some good and not so good movie
microscopy but we will only make this
video if we hit our current goal of 900
monthly patrons so if you would like to
support this Channel and help us hit our
goal so we can make that video you can
head over to patreon.com journey to
micro and please let us know in the
comments below if you have any favorite
movie and TV shows that have done
microscopy either really well or really
bad
foreign
[Music]
the organism here is one of the more
unusual looking microbes we've seen in
the microcosmos in fact calling it an
organism seems strange it looks more
like a coral reef painted by an artist
inspired by both Gustav Klimt and the
pile of trash and if you saw that
painting hanging in a museum you might
pass it by without thinking much of its
subject in the middle of the 19th
century an organism that looked a little
bit like this one did a terrible thing
it could not know that it was doing
something terrible of course it had
recently arrived in a new land and all
it sought was some food but in the
process it starved a nation and killed
many people
the organism was a type of water mold
called phytop Thora in festans which
made its way from North America to
Ireland and with its arrival came the
Great Famine fight up Thora and festans
infected potato and tomato plants
producing lesions on the leaves and
stems and appearing as a white growth
along the lesions the infected crops
rotted making them inedible
[Music]
phytop Thor infestants belongs to a
group of organisms called oomycetes
which translates to egg fungus and we've
actually encountered another destructive
member of this family before early in
our journey through the microcosmos we
recommend going and watching that video
because it is still one of the oddest
events we've ever watched unfold under a
microscope but what we've learned since
then thanks in part to oh my seed expert
Bill fry from Cornell University is that
we were watching a parasitic oh my seat
that had managed to turn a daphnia's egg
into its own vehicle for reproduction on
the rare occasion that we find all my
CDs in our sample it's almost always
under similar Grim circumstances where
these strange creatures have found a way
to grow on the bodies of dead bugs or
Crustaceans and were never entirely sure
if they just happened to stumble onto a
dying organism to feed on or if they
were actually the cause of death
now there are free living oh my CDs that
don't infect other organisms instead
they feed on decaying life but as for
the rest an oh my seat researcher named
Gordon beaks once gave a talk titled
Natural Born Killers
and if you go through a list of Omi CDs
you start to realize just how well
earned that name is
there's a phantomyces astacy which has
wiped out populations of European
crayfish there's phytophthora remorum
which took down oak trees in California
there's Grapevine targeting plasmo para
viticola the maze infecting
paranospirospora philippensus the list
goes on and on affecting everything from
soybeans to Chocolate production and
none of this sounds that out of
character for a group of organisms
collectively called egg fungus right
there are fungi that like to eat dying
things and there are fungi that like to
infect plants we've even witnessed
murderous fungi at work here in the
microcosmos weaving their web around
unsuspecting nematodes
so all my CDs are just one more of these
fungi they're filamentous structures
helping them spread their bodies as they
prepare spores that will help them
spread even further except oh my cities
are not fungi their walls are not made
of chitin the same way fungi walls are
and their nuclei have two copies of
genetic information compared to the
fungi's singular copy
instead it turns out that oh my CDs are
members of a different group of
organisms called stromenopiles making
omicds more closely related to diatoms
and brown algae than they are to fungi
and it's strange to think about it in
these terms diatoms are about as close
as you can get to pacifists in the
microcosmos they enclose themselves in
silica walls and photosynthesize to make
their own food it's like the oh my
cities are killers turning up to a
family reunion full of hippies who spend
their days churning Sunshine into sugar
you can't help but look at them and ask
how did you turn out like that well this
certainly wouldn't be the first time the
two very unrelated organisms shared an
uncanny resemblance birds and bats and
bees all have wings but the wings do not
make them closely related these animals
just went through their own histories of
adaptation and survival and in the
process converged upon the same idea
and there's probably some degree to
which oh my CDs and fungi experienced
something similar they both happened
upon a form and lifestyle that
parasitized and infected profiting on
the Decay that results but at some point
something strange happened the
supposedly parallel Paths of omicds and
fungi intersected sparking collaboration
rather oh my CDs copied fungi
the process by which omicds did this is
called horizontal Gene transfer which
allows genetic material to move from one
organism to another through some means
that is not reproduction it's pretty
common in prokaryotes but as scientists
have learned through omicds eukaryotes
can go through horizontal Gene transfer
as well as part of our ongoing battle
with omicds scientists have had to get
well acquainted with their genes and as
they studied these sequences they found
that some of the species particularly
the plant infecting species had genes
whose Origins had to have come from
fungi through horizontal Gene transfer
in phytophthora remorum the Omi seat
that kills oak trees scientists
estimated that 7.6 of the proteins
released by the organism are produced
from genes that originally came from
fungi some of these copied genes have
given all mycds the ability to break
down plant cell walls others may help
the omicds combat plant defenses based
on our look through the research on
horizontal Gene transfer from fungi to
oh my CDs it's not clear what the
process actually looks like that
information makes horizontal Gene
transfers seem like some Arcane
biological Magic bringing together two
organisms that superficially resemble
each other and making them related
without making them family meanwhile in
the world around us spores spread and
take hold of dead insects and soon to be
dead plants and buried in their bodies
is the evidence of the unusual
collaboration that has made them so
deadly an incomplete answer to the
question
how did you get this way
[Music]
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the Unseen World
that surrounds us
if you're interested in fungi that's a
little less micro you should check out
this video from our sibling channel PBS
eons all about the giant ancient fungi
that once ruled the world and while
you're over there you should also
subscribe and check out the rest of
their videos where they will take you on
a journey through the history of life on
Earth you can find the giant fungi video
and much more at youtube.com eons
[Music]
the folks on the screen right now they
are our patreon patrons they're the
people who make it possible for us to
make this show and also they've gotten
us almost all the way to 900 patrons and
when we get there we will make that
video reacting to wonderful and terrible
screen microscopy so they've gotten us
most of the way there but if you want to
help get us all the way there you can do
that by going to patreon.com journey to
micro if you want to see more from our
master of microscopes James Weiss you
can check out jam and germs on Instagram
and if you want to see more from us
there's probably a subscribe button
somewhere nearby
[Music]